[Music]
well there are a lot of reasons that men
are falling behind in this country but
look at the numbers reveals one
statistic that tracks the decline of
American men almost precisely over time
the disappearance of fathers from the
home between 1960 and 2016 the
proportion of kids living with both
parents decreased by almost 20% the
percentage of children living with only
their mothers nearly tripled in
demographic terms this is stunning
changes to family structure this abrupt
and profound typically are only seen in
wartime and yet if anything those
numbers understate the reality of
fatherlessness in America in the high
income neighborhoods where journalists
and policymakers tend to live not a lot
has changed most kids there still grow
up with their fathers and mothers but in
the rest of the country intact families
are disappearing according to a 2014
study by researchers at Johns Hopkins
University among younger parents without
college degrees seventy-four percent of
mothers had at least one child outside
of marriage out of wedlock birds are now
the rule across the country not the
exception increasingly having a father
at home is the son of affluence but it's
also a cause of affluence especially for
boys boys who grow up with a father at
home earn much more as adults boys who
grow up alone with their mothers tend to
earn less they also have more
disciplinary problems in school they
read less and less well they're less
likely to graduate from high school or
go to college they're more likely to be
unemployed and to live in poverty they
get married less often and when they do
they divorced more they're more likely
to be obese and have asthma they are far
more likely to abuse alcohol and drugs
exhibit antisocial behavior and commit
acts of violence as adults they're twice
as likely to go to prison now these
numbers aren't the result of one study
but of numerous large studies done over
generations the results hold true across
geography and ethnic groups what in
black urban and rural they're always
true boys raised without their fathers
are at terrible
risk there's not much serious academic
debate about that if any the nationwide
breakup of families is a disaster and
not just a moral disaster but a
practical one it may be the largest
public health crisis that we face so
what's driving it well there are many
factors falling mail wages certainly
play a role studies show that when men
make less than women and their potential
dating pool women tend to consider them
less attractive marriage partners fewer
men marry more children are born out of
wedlock some government policies also
discourage marriage particularly among
the poor women on welfare who marry
often see their food and housing
subsidies cut dramatically when recent
report found that almost 1/3 of
Americans know someone who hasn't
married for fear of losing benefits
broader changes in American culture have
also had an effect on marriage and
family formation the dramatic decline in
church attendance and religious
observance is one of these they're
probably other reasons to fatherlessness
is a hugely complex problem but the
point is it is a problem a massive one
and what is remarkable is how rarely
that is acknowledged in public when was
the last time you've heard a democratic
office holder decry the out-of-wedlock
birth rate if you cared about reducing
poverty you would talk about it a lot
but they don't why is that well exit
polling answers that question unmarried
mothers are a critical part of the
Democratic coalition in 2008 Barack
Obama won 74 percent of single mothers
who voted in 2012 he won 75 percent
alienating these voters in any way is
politically risky for Democrats and so
they ignore the problem entirely over
time the progressive left has become
openly hostile to the institution of
marriage
once again voting patterns explain why
it's been more than 20 years since the
Democrat running for president won the
majority of married women in America
unmarried women by contrast vote
overwhelmingly for Democrats in 2012 and
2016 the Democratic party platform never
mentioned the importance of marriage
except when advocating for gay marriage
in 2013 as she was preparing to run for
president Hillary Clinton shot a video
tribute to single mothers quote single
moms are the real heroines she said they
need even more of the help that
grandparents aunts and uncles and good
friends can provide the one group that
Hillary didn't mention biological
fathers Democrats who stray from the
script tend to get attacked Barack Obama
spoke regularly and often eloquently
about the importance of fatherhood and
yet consistent with his party's
orthodoxy he said almost nothing about
men marrying the mothers of their
children and that distinction is
critical studies show that married
fathers are by far more most involved in
their children's lives
you often hear our leaders refer to
caring parents or grandparents or
caregivers or some similar combination
as if the presence of any involved adult
is enough for kids but that's not true
at least for boys the presence of a
biological father in the house makes all
the difference on at least one occasion
Obama suggested that he understood this
in a 2003 speech about gun violence he
gave in Chicago Obama noted that quote
we should do more to promote marriage
almost immediately he was attacked from
the left an article in Ebony magazine
suggested that Obama's remarks were
racist MSNBC ran an op-ed attacking him
and so on he went back to platitudes
Hillary Clinton was right about one
thing being a single mother is difficult
a lot of single mothers work incredibly
hard and they ought to be admired for
that but that doesn't mean that single
motherhood is a good idea for society
it's not it's a tragedy especially for
boys and the rest of us ought to stop
lying about that